welcome to your round five recap of the  2014 u.s chess championships well your  leader alex lenderman kept his lead by  playing to a solid draw but it was the  defending champ godakomsky who seem  lacking in confidence going into the  future rounds i would say that we're  gonna see new u.s champion this year pro  wow  and in the women's championships it was  five-time champion irina crush who  played a dominating game against camilla  began skyte in this position she played  queen f7 check the king moved in the  corner and then she sacrificed her  bishop on f6 if the bishop were captured  then queen takes on h7 would be  checkmate she made her opponent resign  and now she's sitting pretty extending  her lead in first you know and just the  idea was just to keep control of the  game not to let too many crazy things  happen join us for more exciting action  here in st louis at 1 pm central at  uschestchamps.com